تعتبر الولايات المتحده المانحه الرئيسيه
للمساعدات الانسانيه والامنيه للنيجر
ويقدر حجم المساعدات التي تم تعليق بجزء
منها اخيرا بمئات الملايين من الدولارات
تدرك الولايات المتحده ان مصالحها
الاستراتيجيه في افريقيا تمر عبر النيجر
هل تبدو الولايات المتحده في حيره في
التعامل مع ملف النيجر الان الى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه كانت واضحه في موقفها
خصوصا مع ارسال المسؤوله في وزاره
الخارجيه الى النيجر الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تود ان ترى الرئيس بازوم وقد
عاد الى سته الرئاسه في البلاد وتود ان
ترى النظام الدستوري يعود في البلاد ولكن
الاشكال هو كيف نعم كيف
بالفعل هذه هي الاشكاليه وهذا هو التحدي
بالفعل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه يبدو
انها تود ان تستخدم كل الخيارات المطروحه
على المستوى الدبلوماسي تعمل على مستوى
المفاوضات الدبلوماسيه من خلال هذه الجهود
العملي مع المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب
افريقيا والاتحاد الافريقي للتفاوض مع
العسكريين
والعقوبات ايضا تؤدي الى معاناه الشعب في
النيجر والقوات المسلحه سوف تجد نفسها من
دون دعم اعتادت عليه في خلال السنوات
الماضيه في مكافحه الارهاب في تلك المنطقه
في الحقيقه نعم الوكيل زارت
النيجر وصحيح كما تفضلتم لم تتمكن من لقاء
عبد الرحمن سياني وهو الرقم واحد في هذا
الانقلاب تمكنت من
الاحاديث مع مسؤول اذا كان مسؤولا عن
القوات الخاصه ادنيجيريه في الشباب
وبالتالي حقيقه انها التقت
بمسؤولا في هذا الانقلاب او المجموعه
الانقلابيه هو امرا يجب ان نسلط الضوء
عليه طبعا هناك تغير في المزاج بحسب فهمي
بين الفتره والاخرى عند شياني لا اعرف اذا
ما كان هذا هو السبب الذي منعه من لقاء
المبعوثه الامريكيه
من جهه اذا ما ارادوا بالحقيقه ان يروا
باتجاه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ويقول
على سبيل المثال نتحدى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بان تتوقف عن دعمنا في مجال
مكافحه الارهاب هذا سوف يؤدي الى تبعات من
مثل فرض العقوبات الى اخره
المبعوثه الامريكيه كانت واضحه في الموقف
الامريكي حاليا نعم الولايات المتحده
لديها مساعدات عسكريه ولكن ايضا مساعدات
تنمويه مع النيجر وعلاقات مع المجتمع
المدني ومع الشعوب ومع الشعب في النيجر
وعلاقات مع الاحزاب السياسيه من معارضه
ومن حكومه بالاضافه الى علاقات اقتصاديه
مع النيجر هو اعتقد بالتالي انه من خلال
عدم التفاعل بهذه الطريقه وعدم تسميه
الامر ان اعتقد ان الحكومه الامريكيه
تحاول ان تفسح في المجال باكبر قدر ممكن
للحل السياسي ان يعمل في النيجر ايضا مع
المجتمع المدني وايضا دعما ومسانده لشعب
النيجر ايضا تخشى من نفوذ روسي ان يحل في
في النجر هل هذا الخوف في محله فعلا اعتقد
ان هذا الخوف بمحله بالنسبه الى النفوذ
الروسي نتحدث عن استخدام قوات فاجنر في
النيجر هناك فرق بين القول ان هناك قوات
سوف تصل الى المنطقه قوات فاجنر ومن جهه
والقول ان روسيا سوف يكون لديها نفوذ اذا
السؤال المباشر هل سوف تصل قوات فاجنر الى
هذه البلاد وهل سوف تستخدم نفس التكتيكات
الكارثيه التي استخدمت في بلدان افريقيه
اخرى هذا هو مبعث القلق بالنسبه الى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهذا يندرج في
السياق التنافس بين روسيا والولايات
المتحده ولكن هذا على الامد الابعد